who's the best person to tell the story
are you doing first person narrator
third person I
let the protagonist tell me I know that
sounds like so woo woo writerly but I've
told stories from first person I've told
from
third I've told both my book H in the
woods I have I think six or seven
different points of view uh that are all
working through that novel so and that's
just kind of how it came out I didn't
sit down to plan that it was just like
oh this one's talking to me now oh now
that one okay I guess we're doing a lot
of points of view here but then some are
just one straight point of view some
third person some first that's really I
I don't really know how that
happens well the POV is it of usually
the criminal the detective the victim
I've done all you've done okay so
there's no hard and fast rule not for me
I
think you know I I think it's and I've
heard other writers say this too the way
a story comes to you because you know as
writers we're just sort of always
um for me anyway I'm like story just
kind of comes in different ways I may
not even be thinking about oh what's my
next story and it just sort of comes at
me and approaches me and that
that in that way that a story comes to a
person I I believe
is guides how it gets told and it sounds
very general but if I'm attracted to a
story was originally attracted to the
the story of hole in the woods because
of the victim and that was a very
haunting sto personal story for me it's
a based on a true story and I got to
know the victim's father a bit and was
tracking for years because it was a Cold
Case her story so I was very interested
in it it started with her um so she gets
a point of view I naturally had to tell
her point of view cuz the more I got to
know her and her family it just had to
happen but that story is also told
through
investigators and it's also told through
killer eyes um because I thought that
they were very had a very interesting
point of view once I got to kind of
understand or get maybe just know a few
more facts about what they did and who
they were
um so I think it just depends on how a
story comes to you another story that
I'm working on which is a historical
like historical CSI set in France the
story came to me through the main
investigator and who's male and I
typically tell female Pro I typically
have female protagonists so that's been
interesting to to and then I studied his
life and so I became so interested in
his life that it just that's how the
story started to unfold kind of more
about his point of view of how he came
up with all these Crim solving
techniques
so yeah when the story opens is there a
a rule of usually is it from the POV of
the victim or again there's no it just
depends on the story it really just
depends on the and the story type it
depends on the story how it came to you
and I think also the story type but I do
believe that you have to set up what
I've noticed about really pretty much
any Crime Story type that I've studied
whe whatever genre whatever tone setting
is you obviously you have to set up the
stakes and the stakes are always
typically murder somebody's been killed
there's there's a crime that needs
investigating so the crime is always set
up very
quickly if not within the first page
then very soon
after and that that goes back to sort of
um come in in the middle get out early
right come in late exactly and you know
some sometimes you see it from the
investigator's point of view sometimes
you see it from the victim's point of
view
um yeah some sometimes it just depend
sometimes it's from the criminals point
of view I'm thinking more of novels
typically do that but yeah just but but
you're you're getting that set up like
pretty fast pretty
quickly can we talk about a character
that's under duress from guilt whether
it's guilt from a crime whether it's
guilt for not saying something uh
whether it's guilt for maybe overlooking
evidence it was a book that I just read
and it's all told from the protagonist
point of view but we find out I'm just
going to spoil it because I have to um
but we find out as we journey through
the story with him that he is also the
killer um and he's telling us this story
because he is so riddled with guilt and
so and and really the way that the
killing happened was um
very accidental coincidental so it's not
like a you know premeditated hardboiled
kind of murder it it unfolds as sort of
an unfortunate series of events that he
caused and he's completely riddled with
guilt about it um so in a sense like
that drives the I mean really drives the
story and and the investigation that he
does if I could go to prisoners and talk
about
guilt uh prisoners is a really
interesting case study in
guilt
uh a crime is
committed and there are two protagonists
two investigators so it's also a very
interesting just a very interesting case
study in in a very unusual story set up
with two protagonists who are Jake jonal
and Hugh Jackman one is a traditional
detective so you have a very traditional
cop mystery kind tracing down Trails of
evidence and then you have Hugh
Jackman's character who's a father and
his daughter's been kidnapped and now
he's going to investigate to find his
daughter because he doesn't think the
cops are doing enough um and then his
friend's daughter has also been
kidnapped so you have two sets of
parents parents and they're all riddled
with guilt in the way that they're
handling they all handle the
investigation very differently and they
all become very guilt-ridden in terms
the guilt grows in terms of what they
are doing what they're not doing what
they should be doing what they shouldn't
be doing so it's it's a very very um
that one is such a good example of of
how guilt plays a very big role in
driving what a character does I guess or
doesn't do I think you do see in in
most uh crime stories at least one of
the characters has an element of guilt
that they're dealing with and that will
drive that person to hide
themsel stay out of view right or hide
something hide information um it will
drive them
to nervous actions just nervousness and
the these could be physical reactions
like sweating or um uh jitteriness un
uneasiness like if you're looking for
visual character things you could go to
that extreme which is an interesting
obstacle to provide your story because
now you have
somebody basically a witness to
something has gone missing so if a
person is so driven to guilt there's
usually a reason why and it's usually
connected to the case in some way and
now that connection is severed so
that's a great obstacle for an
investigator to deal with
um it's yeah so
there's there's physical manifestations
there's a lot of I think
guilt the man manifestations of that is
hiding whatever that hiding looks like
for that person again whether it's
hiding themselves hiding information um
hiding someone else um
that's it's that you know wanting to
cover things up right wanting to keep it
quiet and
unexposed we talk about the role of a
journalist in a mystery or thriller how
active are they how much are they seen
as the antagonist at times or the hero
depending on the POV of the characters
right right um are you saying a journal
who's not the protagonist then or that's
a good point yeah I guess some someone
who's maybe a side character right and
how much are they allowed to be part of
a certain ride in in solving a case or
maybe they're seen as the pesy please
stay out of the way you're you're
ruining for us you know I mean that's
those are all right real things that
happen exact I love um I think that the
journalist serves as the type of
character who can do things and be
things and be places and into things
that a legal investigator somebody under
the authority of the law like an FBI
agent or a detective can't do right
because those protagonists typically
have to work within the confines of the
law what their job you know the legal
confines that we have but journalists
um you know they can get away with a
little bit more and amateur detectives
they're I mean they would be considered
an amateur detective and so any amateur
detective can sort of get away with a
few more things so that's fun for a
writer or Creator to play with you're
you're
giving this other Outlet to the
investigating the crime you're also they
can be pesky as you say and that gives a
nice obstacle to the
investigator I don't competition sorry M
or competition yep yep yep
um yeah it's I think it's really fun um
I think they need to have a reason for
being there other than like this is my
job and my editor assigned me to it I
mean okay that can be the surface reason
fine but like it just makes it a little
more interesting like what's the real
reason you're so in involved in this
particular crime like always giving our
characters other layers of motivation
you
know